[Music]
welcome back new photographs this
morning of President Trump wearing a
mask publicly for the first time
yesterday during his visit to Walter
Reed Hospital the president who met with
wounded soldiers and medical workers
told reporters he loves masks in the
appropriate locations but still believes
they have a time and place joining us
right now with reaction is the executive
vice president of the Trump Organization
Donald Trump jr. and Don it is good to
see this morning thanks very much for
joining us it's my pleasure Maria how
are you yeah great interesting to see
your dad donning a mask obviously things
are serious you've got the potential of
the second spike how is Kimberly doing
we know that Kimberly has contracted
kovat along with a top convention person
is she okay she's 100% fine hi she's you
know zero symptoms zero anything we're
in quarantine obviously and I am too
because of proximity but other than that
you really wouldn't know that there's
anything even going on so it's been it's
been good under the circumstances it's
as good as it can get and I also saw my
father look pretty good in the mask the
other day and you know I think what
people also have to realize when he
talks about there being a time and place
anyone who comes into proximity with him
is literally tested that day is
literally tested moments before they
allow access so he's obviously going to
be much less susceptible to this than
anyone else because literally there is a
daily screening process if you're gonna
even be within proximity to him so I
think that's important for people to
know but when he's going to Walter Reed
to visit you know our Sikh and our
wounded soldiers he's going to take that
very seriously
yeah but people are taking seriously the
idea that we are seeing a second wave
potentially and and spikes in some hot
spots across the country what does that
mean for the convention Don and and what
about the idea that look the Democrats
have already said they're going to do a
virtual convention there are polls that
have Biden either tied with Trump or
actually leading Donald Trump your
thoughts of all of these worries going
into the convention and then of course
the election well I think for the
Democrats of course they want to do a
virtual
invention because there's no enthusiasm
for Joe Biden he can't get people to
show up a rally if he was able to do
rallies so this whole scenario is really
you know the ultimate best case scenario
for Joe Biden and his campaign they
don't want him on the stump they don't
want him speaking to reporters they
don't want him ad-lib honestly they
don't even want him on a teleprompter
because he can't even get that right so
for them it's sort of the ultimate I
mean I think with our convention there's
a lot of people that want to do it they
want to be enthusiastic but we can do
that and we can do it safely we can take
the necessary precautions we can protect
the people that are going to be there we
can implement things that you wouldn't
necessarily normally implement a
convention to do so so they're gonna
take it very seriously we're gonna do a
great job with it and it's going to be
an awesome event what what does the
president need to get these numbers up
are you buying these polls she looks
like one after the next it's a real
tight race in many cases Biden is
leading the president well listen I
think when you have the media onslaught
where media has just totally abdicated
their position to objectively look at
both sides you know they're not looking
into any of Biden's past they're not
looking into any of his history they're
not looking into his family's graph
they're not looking to how insanely soft
he's been on China throughout his entire
career and let's not forget this is a
50-year career in Washington DC they're
trying to run him like he's a moderate
outsider this guy is the epitome of the
swamp so they want to do whatever they
can to keep the American people from
actually seeing Biden he hasn't been
defied and and the media is trying to
make sure that no one gets to define Joe
Biden because once he is you'll you'll
see how terrible this notion could be
for America which is why you're out with
a upcoming book a liberal privilege
you're gonna talk a lot about Biden in
that book write yourself publishing a
book when is it coming out hundred
percent you know I guess one of the
offshoots one of the only positive
things of Quarantine you know for the
last few months was I had a lot of free
time and I was looking into it and
actually went on and hired a researcher
just to do it myself as I said if the
media is going to totally neglect this
guy this history these terrible trade
deals especially now in the post kovat
nineteen world where we're gonna
actually have to deal with China and
deal tough with China which is what
Trump's you know that's his wheelhouse
that's his forte he's the only guy to do
it in modern American history you know
that Joe Biden can sell this notion of
well now we're gonna be by American
after 50 years of legislation that sent
our jobs that sent our American dream to
China it's asinine but I'm sitting there
looking whether it's you know hunter
Biden whether it's Joe's brother whether
it's the sister the entire family has
enriched themselves off of Joe Biden's
publicly funded office he won't release
his documents from 30-something years in
the Senate that are sitting at the
University of Delaware these aren't like
private notes that he had as a citizen
this is while he was a senator in the
United States paid for by the American
taxpayer and somehow that's magically
off limits
you know Brett Cavanaugh's high school
yearbook was not off limits according to
Democrats yeah his high school yearbook
but Joe Biden's Senate Papers no no we
can't touch this so it's about hypocrisy
it's about the double standard and you
know I called it liberal privilege
because we hear a lot about privilege
these days but liberal privilege is the
ultimate because they can say one thing
do the other and never get called on it
mmm look at the meantime the critics of
you of your father continue stepping it
up just in the last two weeks you had
the mayor of New York actually painting
black lives matter mural right outside
of Trump Tower and Fifth Avenue in New
York City this is where you work every
day right do you pass this new mural
here here's the shots of the mayor
actually painting it right outside of
Trump Tower your reaction well listen
it'd be nice if the mayor actually did
something to help the people of his City
he's busy they're playing arts and
crafts but what has he actually done
other than oversee the destruction of
New York City the guy's you know it's
literally gross incompetence but he'll
go there for a photo op what happened to
the billion dollars almost a billion
dollars that we're literally just lost
on him and his wife's pet projects in
New York City now he wants to defund the
police take 1 billion dollars out of New
York City's Police Department's budget
what do you think is gonna happen with
that you see police officers retiring in
droves you want to stop senseless
killings like George Floyd guess what
the answer is
not driving experienced dedicated loyal
police officers into early retirement
and filling those that void with
inexperienced people who may not have
qualified otherwise but are only getting
the job because you need someone there
the guy doesn't know what he's doing
it's gross negligence and honestly it's
worse it's just sheer incompetence but
again he can play arts and crafts for
the photo up and it's as though all of
the things and all of his failures are
totally forgotten but the media will
give him that benefit it's going to keep
going and in fact de Blasio Hillary
Clinton they all want mail-in voting I
want to talk to you about that because
there was a city councilman among four
people facing voter fraud charges in New
Jersey
we've got umpteen stories of this deluge
and mail-in ballots forcing election
officials in New York Pennsylvania
Kentucky to take two times as long to
count votes in primary elections how
much of this election is going to be
mail and voting do you think done well
the Democrats would like it all to be
mail-in voting yeah you've seen that you
know how often have Republicans won
after the fact when people show up
magically I found a bucket of ballots
all in my car they're all Democrats no
four days later it's truly disgusting
over over the weekend we saw a cat a cat
that has been dead for 12 years since
the end of the Bush administration got a
voter registration form in his home in
Atlanta this is what's going on a mail a
mail clerk someone who worked for the US
Postal Service pleaded guilty over the
weekend for altering ballots you think
the Democrats aren't going to take full
advantage of this they're running around
bragging that they were to manipulate
Trump rallies on tik-tok but they're not
going to take advantage of mail-in
voting Democrats have even said it's
terrible you're right all right real
quick final question here John will you
run for the mayor of New York now my
only focus right now is making sure that
my father wins in 2020
I see the policies that he's done I see
the economic results we've seen it in
the job numbers Donald Trump did the
impossible Donald Trump accomplished the
holy grail of American politics
raising the
job numbers for people raising the
minimum wages for the lowest income
earners watching their wages go up for
the first time in modern history Donald
Trump did it all before he's the guy
that can do it again
clearly not swamp creature Joe Biden who
has an accomplishment record that is
non-existent in 50 years in Washington
DC so maybe maybe you consider it after
the president wins then mayor of New
York is not really my kind of job but
who knows all right good to see you Don
thanks very much for being here